[Music]
[Applause]
David Carr former number one overall
pick by the Texans back in 2002 now a
network analyst for NFL Network you can
see NFL network uh with David Carr on it
NFL Total Access which airs Tuesdays
Wednesdays and Fridays at 7 Eastern good
to see you again uh the Caleb Williams
situation here where his dad came out
and said you know maybe he doesn't go to
Arizona was there any thought that you
weren't going to go to the Texans that
you didn't want to go to the Texans when
you were going to be the number one pick
no
um I think I think this is just such a
different world man
where I mean I understand I get it like
I don't necessarily love what's going on
in Arizona it doesn't
it doesn't give me warm and fuzzy
feelings about playing there with what
I've seen going on so I don't blame
Caleb I would do the same thing I never
had that opportunity I I was just so
excited to be able to
playing the NFL I was so naive though I
mean I didn't know the Texans were gonna
I mean this franchise
new franchise I was I was kind of just
excited to play I didn't know we weren't
gonna
be able to compete you know it's like
let's just yeah it's fair right this
isn't this isn't the wax this isn't
Fresno State we're gonna we're gonna be
able to compete with the Ohio States and
we're gonna be able to get in there with
the Texans and compete with all these
other guys that we just were we were so
far behind so do you think if you had
gone you know I've mentioned that
Mahomes going to the Chiefs uh you know
some of these guys established
quarterbacks now went to better
situations
um that that 10 picks is so I mean
that's a huge difference when you're
going to a team that has a really good
coach and some skilled position players
do you think of you had gone later in
the draft but maybe to a better team
that maybe you would have had a better
career instead of getting sacked 65
times every year
there's no doubt I
think about that all the time so I
remember even being in Pittsburgh uh
playing in a preseason game
and here comes Ben Roethlisberger picked
in the middle of the first round and I'm
like this is all they need they just
need a quarterback they got a great
football team and there's there's
situations like that all over the place
you see where Aaron Rodgers lands he
sits there for a while and he's got to
be you know he's got to be on TV and be
in that awkward Green Room moment where
oh man they haven't taken he lands in a
perfect place for the Hall of Fame
quarterback to kind of show him the
ropes even though it was a little rocky
at the beginning he got to he got to
jump right in there so oh there's no
doubt man I mean it's
used to always tell me only good is the
guys around you and this is this is a
team for a reason inside our Super Bowl
rings when I got the New York Giants it
says team it literally that's the only
word on the inside of the Rings so
yeah this is uh this is a this is the
the best sport in the world because of
that because it's not individually based
there are individual players that can
stand out and make plays but I think
you're only as good as your left tackle
and if you're left tackles
Tony baselli who can't lift his arm and
you put your right tackle over there and
he tells us it it turns the ACL in in
the first week of training camp and now
you're trying guys out on Tuesday to go
play Dwight Freeney in Indy it's gonna
be bad man so yeah
um why did the Rams move on from Jared
Goff
you know I think that
teams get enamored with
um
well first of all I think that Sean
McVay obviously is one of the best play
colors in our league and I think that he
saw an opportunity here's what happened
Bill Belichick exposed his D his offense
he really brought a lot of pressures and
Sean isn't really a guy that will will
pick up the blitzes like that will
change protection and kind of handle
that stuff
and so he he had a weakness and he went
out and said Matt Stafford is the best
quarterback in the league at beating the
Blitz and making off schedule plays and
so he pinpointed that and Jared wasn't
necessarily that guy right but the
system had a little bit to do with that
as well
so Sean brilliantly grabs Matt inserts
him in and we saw it we saw the pressure
beating ability the sidearm no look
throws into those pressure looks we saw
it all into the Super Bowl and and
that's why he did it that's why teams go
out
because they it's not necessarily Just
Jared gospel because now we see him in
the kickoff game when he's leading the
Detroit team that who would have thought
that I'm so happy for him it's great
um he has the ability second level
throws intermediate level throws Jared's
as good as anybody in the league and
that offensive system that they have in
Detroit is they live in that world they
live in the play action past that 15 to
20 yard throw area he's great there so
it was just it was just a fit thing you
know Sean McVay pinpointed her weakness
in his in his scheme and he had to get
better because he wasn't going to change
who he was he wasn't going to all of a
sudden just start you know taking guys
out of the pass route and protecting you
know that wasn't him he's he's gonna
move the pocket play action spread him
out
be aggressive you know and attack so he
had to find a guy that fit that role and
that was perfect
give me something odd that could happen
every year something happens where you
go oh my God who would have predicted
that like Jalen hurts leading the Eagles
to the Super Bowl Brock Purdy is going
to play for the nine start for the
Niners in uh the NFC title game you got
one that you'd go here's one for you
keep an eye on this yeah
yeah Justin fields for me when I watched
the film he's as good as any quarterback
in the league throwing the ball at that
intermediate level down the field and we
started Ohio State and what I think the
I think the the biggest question mark
for me is can Chicago
Paris scheme to this guy's talent
because he ran for 1100 yards I mean
he's he's he has so much ability you
know he's farther along than Jalen hurts
was is it just in my opinion as far as
being able to put pressure on the
defense he has all that raw talent and
he has the ability to push the ball down
the field when I watch it schematically
they they limited him you know and they
made it very difficult for him okay so
what's your what's your bold prediction
of Justin Fields then or the Bears
but they can win that division for sure
okay they absolutely can so I think that
and then he can be on the fast track to
be in a an All-Pro player like that's
that's how good I think he can be so but
I think this I think the offensive staff
has to they got to carry their weight
you know they they he has a they run a
system that's similar to Green Bay or
you know somebody like Kyle Shanahan
like that's kind of the world they live
in it's not necessarily
um what like Philly does you know or
what they're going to do in Indy with
you know with Richardson like it's it's
got to be adapted a little bit so that's
that's my question mark and uh if they
can answer that question they're going
to be a good football team David Carr
NFL network analyst the former number
one overall pick by the Houston Texas
joining us on the program
every year I I tempt myself sometimes I
go too far and I go this is the year for
the Chargers
okay
and they and they always proved me wrong
that it's not the year of the Chargers
um is this year any different
I like Justin Herbert a lot and I think
that that's not like saying this in this
outlandish statement anybody that
watches the film or sees this guy play
quarterback from the time that he
stepped on the field in a weird
situation with Tyrod Taylor like he just
gets it he sees the field very well
spatial awareness and timing and zip on
the ball there's I don't know if there's
anyone better than him in the pocket
so Kellen has Kellen Moore coming over
from Dallas he's a vertical passing guy
we saw the Cowboys you know and they
didn't have the success from a win
standpoint but we saw them really push
the ball in the field and Justin's and
he's got a lot more ability than Dak in
that world
so I they have the tools heckler's still
there they have vertical elements and
they're passing a big physical wide
receivers tied in
so I think the question is going to be
can they handle situational stuff that's
really been the issue you know we
watched them they they always score move
the ball but man it's like I watched
some of that situational stuff and
that's what Coughlin used to just preach
I keep going back to that but it's like
that's what it that's what it is like at
the end of the at the end of the day
it's about winning situations and about
handling those correctly and if you
don't work through that like every
Friday we would go in media and Tom and
we would watch teams mess up situations
for an hour we would just he would just
and it was from the last week we didn't
have to go back in time like there were
an hour's worth of film of head coaches
just screwing it up
and we would sit there and say what
would we do here what are we doing this
and there's a reason that they won two
Super Bowls there
um you have to you have to dial in on
that so it's not a quarterback thing
it's not a talent thing it's a man get
the thing right in the last two minutes
of the game so that sits on Staley for
sure but if they can do that they
absolutely have enough Talent no doubt
who goes farther the Jets or the Giants
well now you're you're tugging on my
heartstrings now man so I think I think
that so waller for me is the best
matchup from an offensive standpoint in
the league if he's healthy so last year
he was dealing with a hamstring they
still know he's dealing with a hamstring
so they're going to have to they're
gonna have to put him on a pitch count
so they had to pull him out of practice
in New York because Daniel wouldn't stop
throwing the football and I don't blame
him because he's open like unless you
have Derwin James on your team he's
going to be open every time right so and
there's only one of those guys so I'm I
it's gonna be great I think it's going
to be fun for for New York fans in
general because the fact that the Jets
have obviously Aaron Rodgers and he's
inserted himself there they're going to
be a good football team they beat the
bills last year with Zach Wilson and
they almost did it again with Mike White
so you're going to tell me that they add
Aaron and they're not going to be a good
football team like that's going to
happen so that's going to be that's
gonna be a lot of fun I'm personally I
think that Isaiah Simmons like adding
him to Winx defense I think that defense
is going to be a top 10 defense and I
think offensively adding Waller if he
can stay healthy daquan's gonna have a
monster here's why I picked him first in
my fantasy draft take on Barkley so he's
going to have extra running lights he
ran against the like loaded boxes I mean
it was every time for him so they need
they needed a guy to kind of pull
coverage and they have that guy like
Brian Day ball is great
he's great schematically but he also
brought over a physical uh a mentality
that you have to have in New York and I
think it's going to be a lot of fun man
so I'll say Giants but man the Jets are
going to be a great team investor that's
a tough division
Kansas City Chiefs without Chris Jones
and perhaps without Travis Kelsey a
bigger loss Chris Jones or Travis Kelsey
uh tough man I think I I always said
that they were the same person on both
sides of the ball because Travis gets a
lot of attention but Chris is the guy
that when I I just happened to pop on
the network the other day and they're
showing the AFC Championship game and so
I should start watching it and every
time they needed to stop or a play on
third down Chris made it and like well
what are you going to do now you know I
love Steve spagnoli he was my defense
coordinator in New York but he's going
to have to bring extra pressure they're
going to have to put themselves in
vulnerable positions now with that young
secondary like they don't have the
ability to just rush forward and get
there because they're an average defense
you know so now you have an average
defense without a game record like Chris
Jones you have to kind of create
pressure with guys coming off edges that
that puts your back end in some suspect
situations but on the other side you
don't have I saw the same thing in the
same game right third down fourth down
like I saw Pat Mahomes turn down an easy
first down throw on fourth down to push
the ball down the field that Travis
Kelsey for a touchdown that he wasn't
open like he was not open so it's like
there's so many times in the game where
you watch Patrick
after he's gone through his progression
where's Travis and then they just kind
of do their thing he's not there right
for at least at least tonight yeah so I
think that that's going to be that's
going to be an issue for them unless
unless pack can do what he did last year
so when he lost Tyreek everyone was like
oh they're not gonna be good and all I
did was say well all he has to do is
start to become and I said it and he's
like oh my gosh
he's just scratching the surface on how
good he can be because physically he
does all this exciting stuff but he
hadn't quite yet mastered ripping
through progressions and getting it to
the open guy in space he's just kind of
scratching the surface of that he did an
excellent job that last year he's going
to be asked to really really Elevate
that you know tonight and in the next
couple weeks if Travis is going to be
around because that's that's a big ass
man we haven't seen him play without
Travis Kelsey or Tyree kills since his
very first start week 17 when it didn't
matter and we just haven't seen it so we
have no idea what they're going to look
like
always great to catch up with you
appreciate your insights thank you
that's uh David Carr NFL network analyst
fritzy of course is big on the New
Orleans Saints this year winning the NFC
South I think it was because we were
going to have David Carr on therefore
fritzy was talking about Derek Carr
yesterday could have been a little of
that there may have been a little that's
what I thought